how has it been then kind of watching
the campaign slightly from afar if
you've been enjoying it its laksa days a
girl it's tedious I think we'll have the
rest of the country I'm thinking is this
the best they can throw together shall
we say it's a slow start and give an
example of how that they're not roughing
only one another up yet Jeremy Corbyn
yes to you now staff football policy
about you let's have more democracy in
football and it he gave Bayern Munich in
Germany as the ideal club the same our
II did so by an elected the president of
adidas as its president it's the most
multinational cooperation company in the
world every member of its supervisory
board bar one is from a top
international multinational it's exactly
the opposite so Corbin got it totally
wrong and none of the other parties
managed to point that out
used to me kinda shows it's it's pretty
slow and he's pretty boring do you agree
with that slow and boring well I don't
know enough about the Bundesliga to take
that one on the boat but no I I just was
supposed to be a brexit election and
that somehow hasn't yet happened and
partly because of Johnson's gaffes one
of the other on the Labour Party's had
these bizarre ideas about the National
Ocean and BT and free broadband I mean
the the so bizarre that it's
preoccupying people's attentions but I
think in the next week or so we'll get
back to the fundamental this year but
you know where the country goes and that
does revolve around brexit I think it's
interesting isn't it because it feels
like with these elections parties go
into them with a clear strategy like
labor want to talk about the domestic
agenda the Conservatives will talk about
brexit and yet then events come along
that drag out all of course of course
one of these has been the floods that
have hit a big part of the country over
the last week I just wonder whether
politicians will be judged a lot on
their response to that I think we could
just have a little listen to Boris
Johnson getting heckled
as he visited and some of those floods
hit areas this week
[Music]
is really in particular that you like us
to do to thank know what man you're
gonna get it y'all just omit Ferris we
will do everything we can to tell me
where your where your home is
it's over there
I mean how important do you think events
like this can be in election campaigns
uh my village is flooded I've got some
bags outside my house by all
constituents is flooded with people's
homes ruined in businesses it can be but
I don't think it will be because that
you know there's anger but it's kind of
it's all of you
you know if the council's not there
blend the council if Annie turned up as
generally quite a popular impede Milo
Clare when I was there addy got a good
shouting out what do you do out people
right and that and you know they ought
to be angry but but it's that's I don't
Lynn this gonna affect the election if
if Johnson happened that we've gone up
it would have been a very very serious
error by him a major error he sent one
of his ministers up and one of the
problems is that people don't know I'm
at the meeting knows but you're not
going to put kind of you know second
second line Minister on on the headlines
so even when cylinders go it needs to be
the big figures in this election that
means the leaders leaders are nothing in
this election so he was late he got a
bit of a kick in but it's not gonna
affect the results anyway well if it
have been Tony Blair or David Cameron
they'd have been there on day one and
they would have conveyed empathy which
Johnson doesn't I mean he the Tories
regard him as a great electoral savior
I'm afraid I don't think he's showing
signs of that I think to be a really top
class politician an effective Prime
Minister you have to have this ability
to empathize with people and their
problems
and he doesn't and then he comes across
as dishonest a bit of a phony and his
record of you know dishonest areas
unfortunately shows through and he just
didn't come across right but that also
go with with when Joe Swinson went if
that that didn't really work when Gina
Maccabiah went he was able to go say I'm
here before Johnson basically where is
he so you got a hit on that but the
empathy V me what do we do you know
these things kind of sit alongside but
the cynicism that's out there kind of
reinforces a they're all useless they
only turn up for a photo opportunity
they don't turn up they don't
nope and I think this cynicism and this
hostility to politicians is a theme that
it's been there a long time I think it's
becoming a big factor in in how people
look at this election it's certainly
like when we go out with the show as
well as different parts of countries and
then we pick up all the time I think
that kind of cynicism towards politics
towards anything changing at all and how
you respond to that as a politician take
the leaders someone could make a huge
gaffe and I think it's fair to say it's
less likely to be Joe Swenson I think
it's likely to be the people perceive
the two that the two key runners Corbin
and Johnson what makes a big gaff that
could be important
yeah it needs to be a big gap you know
making small ones he's not gonna affect
the result of the election the problem I
think is that the way the politics
certainly the two major parties are
responding to this public mood it's
actually the wrong thing which is
promising more and more and more you
know hundred billion for this a trillion
for that and it's actually just making
people more cynical what I'm interested
in your you know you've obviously focus
on economics quite a lot in your time in
Parliament what do you make of the
spending pledges that we've seen
recently cuz it feels like we always get
election baubles don't we but both sides
racing to point this is real father
Christmas stuff I mean there is a
serious point which is that governments
could and should be investing more and
they can borrow in capital markets at
very low interest rates there is a
technical
but you know people are just going crazy
with that opportunity and the the really
tough stuff which is how you fund public
services and you know hire public sector
pay and more doctors and nurses and
teachers and that's the stuff that can
only really be financed with higher
taxation because the economy isn't
growing nobody's willing to say that on
trees today the Liberals will plant five
trees the Tories are plant ten where
we'll do 15 well we'll do it you know
it's kind of it's not gonna persuade
people that cynicism I mentioned you
know I was out and about a lot over the
last couple of days I mean my old
constituency I got a very friendly
response but I think ever been a
candidate he wouldn't've been as
friendly and now that's quite you know
it's quite interesting to see they that
there is an anger there but it's not
particularly directed at anyone and I'm
not sure turnout I think John Curtis the
pundits that it's going up well if he's
watching I'll I'll put a good bet let's
say 50 quid John I bet it goes down to
you sin it's going up interesting I'll
try and I'll try and work this one out
see if we can hold you to that one
we heard a boy Johnson being heckled
earlier I were talking about angry
impolitic so let's have a little listen
now to the reception that Jeremy Corbyn
got when he visited Scotland this week
about the well of discouraged people
with regards to something
I mean it's a risk isn't it when you got
campaigning that you're going to get
angry mmm to the public harassing you is
it something that you guys have
experienced yeah I mean that was just
one individual but actually Scotland is
a hornet's nest isn't it and coburn is
playing a very dangerous game here
because by tantalizing with this
prospect of an alliance with the SNP
it's feeding the the agenda of
independence I mean we've been very
clear that we do nothing to support the
breakup of the United Kingdom any more
than we support the breakup of Europe so
we have a fairly consistent view on it
that kolben is playing with the SNP as
potential allies and that's a very
dangerous game
there isn't one election it's really
important to understand that this time
the election in Scotland
the election in the north of England the
election in in London they're different
elections they really are and and yet
the kind of the one size fits all is not
going to work in this election there's a
lot of micro elections regional but also
you know where people are bothering by
constituency are they interesting
there'll be there'll be more people
looking at who the individual candidate
is than we've seen before they'd like to
have a good candidate but normally it's
you know a liberal Democrat labour
conservative and that's how I'm voting I
think this time the more people said
let's just see who the person is and if
they've got something bad about them
they said stupid evil things they're
gonna lose votes if they've got a good
story to tell they're gonna pick up some
extra votes and that's gonna be more
important in the results this time and
we could see more unpredictable results
it's also why the aggregate polls don't
tell us a great deal I mean the
Conservatives supposedly have a big lead
but actually it may be very fragile and
in particular regions instances